[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview the
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
and broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the
writer Benedict Spence they'll be with
us from now right up until just before
midnight so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the time speaks to the chief executive
of NHS England Amanda Pritchard who
insists a greater emphasis needs to be
placed on training british-born doctors
and nurses rather than relying on
foreign labor
the eye has an interview with the shadow
Health secretary Wes streeting who says
the NHS often puts the needs of its
doctors over those of its patients
the financial times carries newly
released figures which appear to
contradict forecasts of an upcoming
recession by many experts including at
the bank of England
the mail leads with the tragedy of the
dog walker in Surrey who died after she
was attacked by the very animals she was
walking
the telegraph has its own sit down with
Prince Harry who tells their raw editor
he has enough material for another book
but held back to spare his brother and
Father's feelings
the express has a seamless suggesting
hormone replacement therapy drugs could
be useful in treating dementia patients
that's also the lead story for the
guardian
the star reflects on the untimely death
of the singer Lisa Marie Presley who was
of course the daughter of Elvis
and the mirror marks her passing as well
while the sun brings us news that Oasis
singer songwriter Noel Gallagher is
getting a divorce from his second wife
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jenny
Clement and Benedict Spence good evening
to both of you let's start with the
Times newspaper and the NHS head Amanda
Pritchard she's calling for more doctors
to be a British born rather than using
foreign Medics or what do you think of
this Jenny
uh well Amanda Pritchard is uh saying
there's this over-reliance on foreign
staff three billion pounds a year spent
on agency staff and she says apparently
that the answer is for us to admit more
doctors to medical schools or more
medical students to medical schools
apparently medical schools only accept
16 of applicants and I would say I want
us to be pretty selective about who we
admit to medical school the issue isn't
that there aren't enough doctors being
trained in this country the problem we
have in the NHS is retention uh almost
the same number of doctors who are
trained each year I saw some figures
last week almost the same number of
doctors who are trained every year leave
to go and work in other countries where
they can be paid more or work easier
hours and of course Amanda Pritchard
isn't necessarily going to say that
she's chief executive of NHS England so
it's her way of solving the problem
according to this coverage in the times
is to is for medical schools to offer
more places to people
Benedict do you think Jenny's right and
the problem the real problem is one of
of retention rather than not having the
the available Medics I do think that
that's part of the problem um you only
need to listen to the the current
medical staff who are going on strike
who are saying that actually the the
paying conditions uh aren't actually
good enough to keep many of them in the
job
um but I do think that there is
something to be said in training more
Medics I don't think that what we're
saying if if we decide to train more and
X domestically is that we're going to
let in any old you know all in the
sundry anybody who you know wants to
become a medic can just automatically
become a medical I don't think I don't
think that it's going to be that so much
I think that it's right that a lot of
very talented people don't make the
courses uh every year I also think that
it's right that Brit needs to wean
itself off importing uh Medics from
abroad often from second and third world
countries where their pain conditions
are even worse than they are here and
that's why we go after them in many
cases I think that there's a profound
sort of immorality actually about that
about you know 10 taking Medics from
other countries that other countries
have paid to train and bringing them
over here at the very least I suppose if
you were training them up and training
more people up here and some you know
some of them were then going to other
countries where they were better paid
that might balance out that shift uh to
a degree but I do agree that the the
overarching point here is about
conditions in the NHS but I certainly
think that conditions in the NHS are
going to be alleviated
um by having more doctors and nurses and
that will mean training more
domestically whether or not that means
paying them all just looking at some of
the the detail I'm sure people will be
surprised at the the amount that's paid
for agency staff Health Trust paid up to
2 500 pounds last year for a single
agency nurse shift and up to 5 200 for a
doctor shift and the article goes on
that about half of new doctors nurses
and midwives registered in the UK
received their training overseas it's
costing an awful lot to use a agency
style isn't it Jenny
it is and it's it's a sample and we have
a such enormous problem
NHS anyway
um I guess the issue is that it costs a
lot to uh to train people in British
medical schools as well and we really
need to look at why so many are are
leaving I think the answer is is not
necessarily uh to it's easy for uh the
the chief executive of NHS England to
say medical schools need to train more
staff because that is a a cost that the
NHS doesn't necessarily have to bear
that's the cost of medical schools or
people who are uh who are paying towards
their own uh education
um the real issue is why are so many
people who qualify as doctors um leaving
and I I like the fact that we're
selective in this country it's totally
right that we shouldn't be spending
money on overseas doctors it's totally
right that we shouldn't be robbing other
countries uh of their brightest and best
uh simply because we can pay them a
salary that they they couldn't make in
their own country but it has to start at
home of looking at the figures of why do
so many doctors leave the profession uh
just to say that the chief executive of
NHS Englander is stressing quoted here
saying we will always welcome staff
wherever they come from let's move on to
the eye and this is comment from where's
streeting saying that the NHS is too
often run for doctors and and not for
the the patients that they serve
Benedict
which I think potentially seems a little
bit harsh in some cases given them so
many Medics are leaving because the the
conditions in the NHS aren't good enough
for them um I think possibly this refers
mainly to GPS and I mean a lot of people
especially in rural areas will know the
difficulties in getting GPS appointments
and where streating talks actually in
this interview with the eye about ending
that sort of rush that you get at eight
or nine a.m when your GP surgery opens
and all of the appointments are gone
um and it it basically becomes a service
for people who are you know not in work
that day those are the only people that
can get appointments because they're the
only people that can travel
um so there is that that aspect of the
NHS I certainly think does need to be
done but again uh in order to do that
that will require having more staff
available more staff on hand and I think
that this is very interesting because
it's a it's a it's a labor Shadow Health
Minister
um talking about uh it basically he's
approaching the idea of reform in the
NHS the idea that there needs to be a
mentality away from staff towards
patients and and that's that's curious
because of course everybody talks about
the NHS being this sort of sacred cow
that can't be touched and all that needs
to happen is more money is pumped into
it and it's often caricatured that labor
is sort of more in favor of keeping the
NHS as it currently is than the tourists
but this is as I say a Labor uh Shadow
Minister coming out and saying there
needs to be some sort of fundamental
change and I think it comes as part of a
recognition that even if you throw lots
of money at the NHS even if you try to
streamline it even if you try to improve
it it has reached a point now with all
of the the crises that we see with all
of the strikes that we see where it is
no longer acceptable for anybody to sit
there and go ah this is fine no this is
very clearly A system that is creaking
that is breaking down and it must also
be said as the demographics of this
country shift and people get older and
stay alive a lot longer and the
population ages in general and fewer
people are being born this is going to
continue to be a burden and we are going
to have to find a more sustainable way
of funding and Staffing the NHS because
the current model isn't working now and
it certainly isn't going to be working
in five ten years time well specifically
where screen meeting is promising to end
the 8 A.M Scramble for GP appointments
and to boost pharmacies but but he's
also saying that the the reforms will
take at least a decade
I find this uh this line about ending
the 8 A.M scramble really interesting
Kia Stormer was using it in uh prime
minister's questions this week as well
it's clearly something that the labor
party has decided this is one of their
lines and it's a good one because we've
all had that feeling where we've woken
up with terrible tonsillitis or we've
got a child who's really sick and
knowing that you have to keep redialing
redialing redialing and being on hold
and that you might not get that
emergency appointment that you need it's
not a nice feeling
um and so definitely labor wanting to
appear to be on the side of patients
rather than necessarily even the doctors
in all of this but Benedict's right I
mean we have an aging population here we
haven't solved the social care uh crisis
it's not even the case that spending
needs to uh be at a constant level it
needs to be massively increased over the
number of years because at the older the
population gets the more sick people
they there will be
um so we need some kind of radical
reform and I think 10 years is it makes
sense it's it's the the right kind of
ballpark figure
to the financial times and a little bit
of good news a very little bit of a good
news 0.1 percent to be precise but still
um positive
Benedict
yes Sun brightness amongst all of the
Gloom although I suppose it does need to
be tempered as you say only 0.1 percent
uh growth in GDP whereas it had been
forecast to uh decrease by 0.2 but also
accompanied uh by the um the chief
executive of the Blackstone private
Equity Group uh saying that in his
opinion the UK was being a little
undersold that people were perhaps a
little bit too gloomy about its uh
economic forecasts
um so you know we we are talking aren't
we generally about the sort of the
negative state of the economy and the
lack of productivity in a lost decade of
growth compared to uh other G8 countries
uh G7 countries uh sorry but you know
the the Ft talks about um Jonathan gray
uh the Blackstone CEO who you know he is
a big player in in in the industry
saying that the sunac administration in
his words is putting forward policies
that appear to be working and he doesn't
say that they're necessarily that you
know Rishi sunak is some sort of
economic genius or anything like that
far from it but what he is saying is
that the UK is actually performing
pretty well compared to its competitors
say in the United States in North
America in Europe in the Far East that's
what we're sort of talking about here
because it is a global economic slowdown
uh that we're talking about here now
specifically the Ft uh pays lip service
to the World Cup
um which which is nice to know that even
though we didn't do particularly well it
brought us some very mild respite uh in
in the short term but of course that is
only a temporary blip and it is still
expected that the UK will enter a
recession uh next year that there will
be that slow down so as you say some
bright news but let's not get the
bunting out just yet yes quiet and
Jonathan Gray's saying it in that
article that as you say recession is
delayed not canceled and so we still
very likely to go into recession this
year Jenny
oh yes I think that's very much uh what
analysts are saying although analysts
were saying that the there was going to
be a contraction of the economy by 0.2
percent it's good to hear that that bad
predictions uh can be wrong but the
thing about this good news is does it
really make any difference if we're not
feeling it I mean living standards are
falling at the fastest rate for 40 years
recession or not uh we feel the
Incredible cost of living every time uh
we go to the supermarket we don't feel
like we're bouncing back even if it
looks like the economy it isn't as as
bad as we thought it it it might be
um so the games whatever games there may
be are not being passed down to
households and it does feel like a a
delayed recession I mean there was
there's also you know the potential good
news on the horizon about wholesale gas
prices falling and uh maybe our gas
bills aren't going to be as high as
expected but there's still going to be
double what they were four years ago
um so it's a little bit of good news but
even even the financial time says itself
that the signs of growth lighten the
Gloom and make the rate rise more
lightly so I guess it's uh it's good
news if you've got savings you can make
more interest on your savings but if
you've got a mortgage then maybe this is
even even worse news because if the
economy can handle it the bank of
England will increase interest rates a
little bit more to try and Tackle
inflation and that's going to be even
more bad news if you've got a mortgage
Benedict's potentially more good news in
the express for the treatment of
dementia
uh yes this is the news that well
specifically for women I think that this
is the case as that HRT treatment uh has
been found potentially to uh have some
positive effects
um when tackling Dementia in in elderly
women and helping to sort of halt the
flow of it and it's interesting actually
I was reading another story yesterday
about um I think it was a treatment for
colds or coughs or something had been
found to have
um some sort of positive impact in
treating Parkinson's disease and I I I'm
not an expert in in Dementia or HRT for
that matter but it does seem to me that
you know very increasingly we hear these
sorts of stories about the multi you
know the different uses of different
treatments that have been sort of
discovered for one thing and then can be
applied for others but it's these sort
of terrifying diseases things like
dementia that we are very slowly sort of
finding solutions to and yeah amidst all
the Doom and Gloom uh that we hear about
the NHS for example and the pressures
that are being applied onto it we do
need to remember the fundamental
underlying reason why there is so much
more pressure now on the NH than there
has ever been is because people are
living longer and because science is
discovering more and increasingly sort
of interesting uh and impressive ways of
dealing with diseases that once upon a
time we had absolutely no defense
against so it's again another little bit
of bright news amongst all the Gloom
um and I tell you what dementia is one
of the worst things that one can
possibly imagine so anything in the
flight against dementia I think is is a
is a positive indeed we'll talk a bit
more about that in uh the 11 o'clock
hour but for the moment Benedict and
Jenny thank you
we'll look back on The Life and Legacy
of singer Lisa Marie Presley when we
come back
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Jenny Clement and
Benedict Spence there they are slightly
delayed but uh right on time let's um
have a look at the uh well a couple of
papers that the mirror and the star in
both reporting on the untimely death of
Lisa Marie Presley Jenny
really really saddened by this that poor
family so many
um early deaths in the Presley family
and Priscilla Presley Elvis Presley's
ex-wife Lisa Marie's mother is still
alive and has seen Lisa Marie Presley uh
die so young uh in her 50s she also lost
a grandson Lisa Marie Presley uh lost
her 27 year old son two years ago to
Suicide
um and you do think how much pain can
can one family take really I mean the
mirror here says that Lisa Marie died of
a broken heart it uh reveals some some
things that she said about
um living alongside the grief of her her
son's suicide that it's not something of
course that you ever get over it's
something that you learn to live with
every every waking day but you know an
enormous enormous burden for her and the
poignancy that there were there are
these images of her two nights ago at
the golden Globes the appearances she
gave seeing Austin Taney win his award
um and knowing that she was full of life
two days ago it makes it even more
tragic and The Mirror Has a really
interesting detail in it that Elvis's
mother died aged 46 we know that the
cause of of Lisa Marie's Presley's death
appears to be a cardiac arrest Elvis
Presley uh died of a heart attack so you
know we will we will find out in due
course what the cause of her early death
is but for now it's just I just think
it's um it's extremely sad yes Benedict
um sad is is the only word really isn't
it
I think so I thought that the the stars
from patrons perhaps a little uh not not
in the best taste uh given the
circumstances but um it's I I think
Jenny's roach sort of summed it up very
well but how much sort of uh torment can
one family go through and especially to
have risen in the case of a father to
sort of such Heights to the points where
you know sort of even now in death he
sort of towers over uh aspects of the
music industry and it's a it's a shadow
that you can never really sort of uh get
away from and of course tied up in that
is the misery of of his of his later
years
um and I suppose actually in many ways
you know we're talking about uh Lisa
Marie at the Golden Globes
um about uh for the film or about her
father's life it might it really does
sort of bring home to a sort of a
younger generation sort of the scale
actually of what he went through indeed
Benedict and uh Jenny thank you so much
see you in the 11 hour